Which is better a tiny rolled and filtered
menthol cigarette, or a tall water-filled
mint strawberry tobacco stuffed hookah?
One sure tastes better.
But which is HEALTHIER?
Hey smokers and friends Trace here for DNews
to shatter your hookah dreams.
Sorry to say it, but hookah is real bad.
REAL bad.
A new review published in Respiratory Medicine
says the health impact of smoking hookah is
akin to enjoying 100 cigarettes.
One.
Hundred.
Hookah comes from Persia and India and dates
to the 15th Century.
It was spread throughout the world by the
Ottoman Empire.
In case you've never seen one, the hookah
is also known as a water pipe, shisha, narghile
(NARG-YE-LAY) or hubble bubble.
It has tobacco at the top under a hot coal.
As the heat burns the tobacco, the smoke is
sucked down, through water and a tube, to
the user.
The American Lung Association sees hookah
smoking as a growing problem with youth due
to the misconceptions about it's safety -- their
2007 study of Michigan teens found those who'd
smoked a water pipe were 8-times more likely
to try cigarettes too.
Stats from the CDC show 16 percent of high
schoolers, and 25-40 percent of college students
have tried a hookah -- this is in comparison
to 26 percent of high schoolers who've smoked
cigarettes or cigars.
People believe the water in a hookah filters
the tobacco, but they're wrong...
Sure, the smoke "feels smoother," because
the temperature is lower and has higher humidity,
but the smoke itself is just as bad as -- actually
worse -- any other tobacco-smoking product.
The University of Maryland says hookah smoke
contains HIGHER levels of arsenic, lead, and
nickel, 36 TIMES MORE tar, and 15 TIMES MORE
carbon monoxide than cigarettes.
A study in Cancer Epidemiology, Biomarkers
and Prevention tested if water pipes were
a good alternative to cigarettes -- for people
wanting to kick the habit; when testing the
urine of both, they found chemicals which
damage the nervous system, red blood cells
and eye, throat and nose.
Some levels in hookah-smokers were double
those of the cigarette-smokers.
When it comes to the addictive chemical nicotine
-- cigarettes and hookah are the same.
So YES, it's JUST AS ADDICTIVE, but it gets
worse...
The World Health Organization found the average
hookah session lasts between 20 and 80 minutes.
While you inhale 50-100 mL of smoke in a cigarette,
puffing on hookah for a session net 90,000
mL of smoke!
That's where the 100 individual cigarettes
number comes from.
According to a study in Nicotine & Tobacco
Research: hookah smoking has been shown to
cause stunted lung production, and the CDC
says, smoking hookah while pregnant produces
lower birthweight babies.
Hookah smokers are at risk for cancers of
the mouth, lung, esophagus and stomach too...
Does all this sound familiar?
That's because it's the same thing you've
been hearing about REGULAR smoking.
There ARE non-tobacco products you can smoke
from a hookah which claim to be safer — they're
not.
Smoke from the heat source and the carbon-monoxide
you inhale will still screw up your lungs.
Smoking is smoking, regardless of HOW we inhale
smoke, the lungs aren't all about it.
Do facts like this surprise you?
Who told you hookah was safer?
Share your thoughts with us down below, subscribe,
and if you learned something new -- click
like and tell your friends!
Thanks for watching DNews everyone!